well just about all of you know about  black friday but a lesser known shopping  name the cannabis industry is gaining  traction  green wednesday i believe that has a lot  to do  with people just preparing for the  thanksgiving holiday  helping themselves become maybe a little  bit hungrier and increasing their  appetite  helping themselves helping them engage  with their family members and  create more fun conversations at the  dinner table  according to leafly.com the wednesday  before thanksgiving has become the  second busiest day for the cannabis  industry behind  april 20th dispensaries across the  country offer sales on everything  this one is the newest location for  thrive near cactus and i-15  it has a conveyor belt that brings  products to customers  with fewer people touching it